dear members of the new european bauhaus
collective
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
for the invitation
it is an honor for me to open this first
event
of the new european bauhaus collective
i am very happy to have such a strong
diverse and competent group of
organizations and people
that support the new european bauhaus
initiative
with the creation of this collective
you did exactly what we had in mind
when we launched the project bringing
people together from different
backgrounds
and disciplines not only to amplify good
ideas
but also to create a better future for
europe
and our planet
why is this so important
let's take some minutes to look back at
the original bauhaus
that was founded in weimar and dessau
you all know it quickly developed into a
worldwide
movement the success of this movement
was only possible because the founders
succeeded in combining architecture
with craft and design
with innovation they put the concept
of interdisciplinary into practice
every day and until today
we can see how successful they were
we see their ideas in the buildings of
our cities
in our furniture in fabrics and art
combining art with technology
bringing together innovation and
creativity
is key for deep transformation
and this is why the work of your
collective
is so interesting and so important for
us
but this is not the only reason
why the historical bauhaus can be an
inspiration
for a new european bauhaus
let me mention two more first of all
the historical bauhaus was created in a
time of
profound transformation
people were facing the challenges of
industrialization
the founders around gropius
aimed for solutions that were functional
affordable but also beautiful
and the new european bauhaus is also
looking for this combination of
aesthetics and affordability
but we want to add a very important
third element sustainability
the new european bauhaus wants to match
sustainability with style
we want to show that sustainable
solutions can also be
beautiful the new european bauhaus
brings a cultural element to the
european green deal
it wants to make the european green deal
a tangible
touchable experience and bring it closer
to the people
the third inspirational element of the
historical bauhaus
is that it boldly promoted
new materials like steel and cement
today we also need to look into new
and sometimes old building materials
but this time it's about climate
friendly materials
that need less co2 in their production
process
the new european bauhaus wants to
accelerate
the transformation of the build
environment it wants to scale up
nature-based materials like wood and
bamboo
to support circular design and
architecture
buildings are responsible for 40 percent
of our energy consumption only if we
manage to change this
we have a chance to keep global warming
below 1.5 degrees
if we succeed we will come a great deal
closer
to our big european goal to become
the first climate neutral continent by
2050.
to achieve this we also count on
your support and on your concrete
contributions
you are at the forefront of developing
the new materials and processes
you are the decision makers on new
buildings
and renovations in your cities
you are planning and designing houses
schools and hospitals
you can make this change happen
and bring the bauhaus to a new era
as you know we are still in the
so-called
design phase of the project our concept
is not ready yet
we want to shape it together with all
people
interested and together with you
we see some trends already emerging
and one of the most important trends is
the focus on renovation and reuse of
buildings
in the future it should be an exception
that a building needs to be scrapped we
should use
our resources in a more responsible way
and smart renovation can play a
major role here and that's why the
commission proposed last year
together with the new european bauhaus
the renovation wave we will
present additional measures like energy
performance standards for buildings
that will enhance renovation in the
member states
and it's good to see that there seems to
be
a shift in thinking in the architecture
community
for the first time in its 46 year
history
the pritzker prize was awarded
not for new buildings but for
refurbishment
the architects anne lactom and
jean-philippe vazal
upgraded social housing buildings in
bordeaux
by making them more energy efficient and
more beautiful
and these award-winning architects
showed like many others
change is possible and it is
fun so let's turn our cities into urban
forests
modern and old european cities should
capture co2
instead of emitting it
and this brings me to the last point i
want to share with you today
the role of local governments regional
decision makers
cities and rural communities
this is where the change happens
we need you the mayors councillors
citizens
we need you for the green transformation
on the ground
we know that public procurement plays a
key role
sustainability should become a more
important criterion
in this process we will make proposals
on this later this year
there are already so many good examples
for green transformation in cities and
villages all over europe
we want to give them visibility and use
them
as an inspiration for others
i want to thank you again for your
support
and your contributions to this
initiative
i also want to encourage you to
participate in the new european bauhaus
prize
that we launched last week the good news
is
you still have some more weeks to apply
with your project
we are very much looking forward to get
your feedback from the workshops
that you will have today it will be a
valuable contribution to the design
phase
and your spirit will help us to shape
the concept of the new european bauhaus
thank you very much